more right now on john graves his 10th
start of the year
his first kind of rough outing was his
last outing in san diego other than that
he has really been very very good in
each and every hour
this is on the ground tough play for
trevor's got a circle backhand perfect
but that's a really fine play by trevor
i agree with that but check this out he
starts by working around the baseball to
allow his arm strength to kind of go
through it so he can go towards first
base
reminds me so much of tulo back in the
day
here's eduardo escobar he's been a
challenge in this series he taps one
slowly mcmahon bare hand pickup throw to
first and got him
good play by the second baseman
ryan mcmahon helps john gray have a one
two three first
rocky set to face your diamondback
starting pitcher today the right-hander
taylor widener taylor's fifth start this
year
and his first since april 22nd activated
from the injured list today after a
groin stream the last thing you want to
do is load the bases ahead of this guy
who's been a real problem lately
ryan mcmahon who leads colorado in rb
guys and his 11 home runs are more than
twice as many as any other rockies
player
[Applause]
we're going to miss he missed a slider
that's a big strikeout for taylor
widener one more big out to get for
taylor widener
and it's the recent national league
player of the week josh fuentes who's
back at third today
and the o2 swinging a pop-up into right
moving over into right center is reddick
he will make the catch
and taylor widener escapes a bases
loaded jam in the first first and third
for story who popped to first
in the first inning pitch is lined into
right field for a base hit
nunez scores the rockies lead it one to
nothing
timely hit for trevor story make the
diamondbacks pay for the
mistakes and i don't know if widener's
healthy jack
remember taylor coming off that groin
injury and he is going to have to leave
the ball game
taylor widener making his first start
off the injured list has to leave in the
second because of an injury so here's
dalton varshall left-hand hitting
catcher
and the pitch swing and a miss
got him on a slider
second strikeout for gray make it eight
straight retired
so here's madison bumgarner pinch
hitting for mantiply who came on for the
presumably injured taylor widener john
he's ready to go 1-2 on bum
is gonna be
fuentes to first in time josh stung with
it off the bat i think garner thought he
had himself another hit three perfect
innings for john gray
and here is eduardo escobar 2-2
left field tapia
two steps back he's got it john gray has
been
outstanding andre has been superb
in every aspect as he embarks on the
fifth inning he'll see david peralta
josh rojas and josh reddick
[Applause]
and there's the base hit down the line
peralta spoils gray again it's a lead on
single
you'll get josh reddick to face john for
the second time and he'll drive this to
center field dazza on the run wind
pushing it away from him he makes the
catch
peralta was around second throwback to
first not quite in time
how did
jonathan dazza catch that baseball
fully extended as he went on to the
track and robbed reddick that ball kept
carrying towards left center daza
initially didn't quite take the right
angle and then had to bolt backwards and
with everything that he had he reached
up across his body and it caught the
very end of the glove
unreal catch
as smith
now deals with ryan mcmahon and ryan
hits it towards third escobar has it he
goes to second for one the relay by laba
is strong and it's a double play
the rockies challenged the double play
and guess what they won
watch
labor here at second his foot is going
to come off the bag prior to catching it
the neighborhood play went away a few
years ago
so the rockies are still batting with
two outs and mc and charlie blackman at
second base
and a line drive to left and the rockies
are gonna get a run out of this deal
and fuentes has another double his
fourth in the last 24 hours
rbi double for joshua
first and third no outs down two nothing
and here's katel marte
mattel sends it to center dos is at it
again a diving catch that gets varshall
home
[Applause]
two sensational catches in center for
colorado
rbi for marte it's a 2-1 ball game
slider and marte just puts it in play
this ball just
almost trails back to daza
see that
the last couple feet it kind of
heads back towards the ball magnet in
center
one out andrew young still at first
first pitch to the left-handed hitting
pavemen smith is club deep down the
right field line towards the corner it's
gone
two-run home run pavon smith d-backs
have a 3-2 lead
first pitch swinging on a fastball and
drives it out of here off the facing of
the second deck out there d-backs will
bring the infield in now
jonathan dazza
trying to get the game even at the least
with that tying run at third with a 1-1
hit towards second mcmahon heading home
he's in there beat the tag and varsio
couldn't hang on to the throw
and the rockies have tied it at three
colorado threatening with first and
second and one out and hampson hits a
fly ball to right towards the line long
run for redick reddick racing over and
it one hops against the fence
coming around third and racing for the
plate and the throw is in time to get
gaza
the go-ahead run got down at the plate
on a perfect relay holy smokes here's
steven vogt second and third and two
outs in the top of the ninth in a 3-3
game bard with the pitch to vote
strike three call and daniel takes care
of business
bottom of the ninth inning the rockies
will try to win it they have the right
guys coming up
this ball hammered deep center field way
back got a chance ball game over
trevor story time
story has won it on a walk-off blast